und wir haben gleich einen weiteren
hochkarätigen gast in der leitung der
ministerpräsident vom saarland tobias
hans ist umgeschaltet montag
schönen tag ich grüße sie so nun geht es
morgen auch wir sehen diese telefon mpk
das soll jetzt auch ein lockdown für
ungeimpfte bei ihnen im saarland
beschlossen werden glauben sie wirklich
dass das die vierte wäre jetzt brechen
wird
nein das alleine wird nicht die vierte
welle brechen aber es ist ein ganz
wichtiges element ist die kontakte
runtergefahren werden und zwar vor allem
bei denjenigen die maßgeblich die
pandemie treiben im moment und das sind
eben die menschen die ungeimpft sind wir
haben im saarland mit die höchste
impfquote in deutschland und trotzdem
sehen wir dass es bei ungeimpften
inzidenz von über 1000 gibt während sie
bei den geimpften bei rund 80 liegt und
das zeigt dass die ungeimpften jetzt
eben aus den wesentlichen bereichen des
öffentlichen lebens sich zurückhalten
müssen und deswegen wird es diesen
lockdown geben angefangen beim kontakt
beschränkung zu hause ein haushalt plus
eine person bis hin zum öffentlichen
leben draußen drinnen gastronomie wird
es eben jetzt keinen zugang mehr geben
dass das eine das andere ist dass wir
ganz massiv das impfen jetzt noch mal
hochfahren wir haben uns schon
vorgearbeitet im saarland von der
booster impfquote dritter fünfter platz
auf dritter platz und wir wollen in
einem großen kraftakt im saarland jetzt
dafür sorgen dass möglichst allen
berechtigten die auffrischungsimpfung
gegeben wird aber da brauchen wir eben
den bund denn es ist ganz wichtig dass
wir dann in die impfkampagne jetzt auch
einbeziehen kann andere fachberufe die
apotheken müssen mit rein wie tierärzte
müssen mit reinen die zahnärzte müssen
mit rein und deswegen muss das
entsprechende bundesgesetz geändert
werden damit wir da vorankommen winter
starten können wir die wellen brechen da
stand ja in den letzten pkw stößt schon
drin dass man das prüfen soll jetzt in
der zeit das ist jetzt schon wieder zwei
wochen her warum hat man das in der zeit
eigentlich geschafft warum braucht es
jetzt nochmal dieses telefonat zwischen
allen weil zu prüfen ob apotheker jetzt
auch impfen können das hätte man in 14
tagen einfach mal abräumen können also
erstens gebe ich ihnen völlig recht das
hätte man können abräumen und ich habe
auch die erwartung dass die
parlamentsmehrheit im bund sich dieses
themas jetzt an nimmt man kann gesetze
wenn es in so nah dran badischen lage
erforderlich ist auch relativ schnell
ändern das ist die klare
erwartungshaltung von uns ländern dass
wir da handeln können ich habe unser
land 60 apotheken die
grippeschutzimpfungen machen warum aller
welt sollen die nicht auch corona
impfungen machen können wir brauchen da
wirklich jede impfen und helfende hand
aber ein wichtiger anderer punkt ist
doch auch dass wir im moment sind es die
krankenhaus kapazitäten immer mehr unter
druck gekommen wir haben durch die raw
impfquote bislang immer an der niedrige
hospitalisierung gehabt im saarland
trotz hoher infektionszahlen aber
natürlich kommen jetzt auch bei uns die
patienten patienten aus bayern aus baden
württemberg an wir haben schon über 13
patienten aufgenommen und das bringt
natürlich dann stück für stück auf das
gesundheitssystem in den bundesländern
unter druck die eigentlich noch eine
relativ entspannte lage haben deswegen
wir haben eine nationale pandemische
notlage und ich bin der auffassung wir
müssen deswegen jetzt auch national
handeln und zusammenkommen ob das morgen
möglich ist weiß ich nicht es wird ja
herumgedruckst nach dem motto das soll
keine klassische mpk sein sondern nur
eine unterredung zum
bundesverfassungsgericht urteilt das zu
erwarten steht ich habe da schon die
erwartung dass wir die ganz
grundlegenden fragen nochmal miteinander
besprechen
das muss doch jetzt wirklich gehandelt
werden angesichts der hohen zahlen wir
müssen national handeln das klingt jetzt
ein bisschen nach dem söder plan nach
einem bundesweiten lockdown käme das für
sie in frage was halten sie von dieser
idee ich bin der auffassung dass wenn
man in so einer schwierigen lage und das
scheint ja im moment wirklich das
schwierigste zu sein was wenn der
pandemie bisher hatten dass man dann
zusammen stehen muss und wir haben immer
in der runde der ministerpräsidenten
zusammen mit der bundeskanzlerin lösung
hinbekommen für ganz deutschen dass mama
mehr gut mal weniger gut das stimmt
sicherlich aber ich glaube dieser
schulterschluss dem braucht das jetzt
ganz einfach es wurde zu lange
weggeschaut und wir sollten da mit der
neuen bundesregierung mit der
parlamentsmehrheit zusammenarbeiten ich
jedenfalls bin dazu bereit und wir haben
noch immer was hinbekommen wenn die
ministerpräsidentin ministerpräsidenten
zusammenkam soll das bundes lockdown ja
oder nein
dh dass für bundesweit einheitliche
note bremsenden maßnahmen brauchen das
natürlich als ultima ratio als letzter
schritt auch in london sein aber es geht
doch im moment mal darum dass wir
überhaupt die handlungsspielräume
nochmal herstellen im moment dürfte ein
bundesland wenn es in der notlage kommt
noch nicht einmal in den locker angehen
das sieht das bundesgesetz nicht vor
weil die nationale pandemische notlage
einfach nicht anerkanntes epidemischen
notlage nicht anerkannt ist und deswegen
sollten da die ampel koalitionäre dafür
sorgen dass die entsprechenden
möglichkeiten geschaffen sind es braucht
wird ganz hoch incidents gebiete die
möglichkeit zu zu schließen wir machen
das im saarland mit dem lockdown für
ungeimpfte plus der massiven poster
kampagne wir glauben dass wir damit die
bälle bremsen können aber stellen sich
da einfach mal vor wir diskutieren jetzt
über die frage sollen weihnachtsmärkte
stattfinden oder nicht wenn das nicht
bundesweit entschieden wird oder bei
fußballspielen wenn es dafür nicht
bundesweit einheitliche regeln gibt dann
macht das überhaupt gar keinen sinn dann
entsteht doch ein tourismus von einem
bundesland ins andere
das kann an dieser stelle keiner wollen
und deswegen müssen wir gemeinsam
beraten welche schritte zu ziehen sind
ja das ist ein gutes argument noch
einmal dagegen gehalten der
weihnachtsmarkt budenbesitzer in
pinneberg der wird vielleicht aktuell
nicht verstehen wenn die zahlen doch in
bayern so hoch ist warum er wieder
abbauen muss der gerade aufgebaut hat
naja weil eben in pinneberg doch auch
die patienten ankommen dann eben aus dem
osten deutschlands wo werden thüringen
sachsen sehr hohe infektionszahlen haben
und die krankenhäuser überlastet sind
man kann sich da nicht rausreden durch
unser verteilsystem was ich begrüße es
selbstverständlich helfen wir den
patienten den ich behandelt werden
können in anderen bundesländern im
saarland ist die krankenhaus belegung
auch vergleichsweise niedrig noch aber
wenn diese patienten und patientinnen
alle zu uns kommen kommen wir massiv
unter druck das ist eine frage die sich
in ganz deutschland stellt es wird kein
bundesland verschont bleiben wir sehen
das im moment auch bei unseren
französischen nachbarn die bislang eben
auch weniger betroffen waren die
pandemie rollt in dieser vierten welle
oder der fünften welle wie man in
frankreich sagt da glaubt man die vierte
welle ist schon
ein stück weit rum die wird jetzt über
ganz europa noch mal drüber rollen
deswegen bringt es überhaupt gar nicht
sich die augen davor zu verschließen es
muss gehandelt werden und wenn wir ein
einigermaßen schönes weihnachtsfest noch
erleben wollen dann sollten wir jetzt
schnell handeln und dann kann das auch
noch etwas bringen
sagt saarlands ministerpräsident wie als
hannes danke dass sie sich die zeit
genommen habe ich sehr gern ich wünsche
ihnen einen schönen amt